[Music]
in gym jerk news yeah checked off at the
gym I think I know this one now this
video it's a video keep going submitted
my Squishy wishing a weightlifter was
attacked mid-workout for making too much
noise yeah he put its foot on the
[ __ ] bar whoa I saw this video
actually did a reaction video with the
silent like when we watch was he
grunting and [ __ ] like let you know he's
me I don't watch it you gotta watch the
video I don't run if no no but the guys
like me who's making noises he's just
telling he's just working out on the
corner minding his own business this is
a 19 year old named Charles he's a
[ __ ] kid too
yeah I could hurt this kid cause what
charles-antoine Lalonde past oh my god
it was Asian it's some French like
Canadian place huh I see all this French
[ __ ] on the wall Oh
for some reason he I thought he was like
a big Chinese kid that's what I'm saying
I don't go off your memory every when
you say you see this [ __ ] and
you said you knew there was a French kid
that is Tiny's there might be but
Canadian french-canadian over to my to
my defense I was I was looking at a very
small very small video on a very small
phone uh-huh pollo far away the worst
[ __ ] key witness ever did five miles
down that way yeah so what happened at
the scene of the crime well let me tell
you something here after this year the
court passes telling me you can't look
Chinese right here you could look
anything but black yeah but you can't
look Chinese yeah the kids pretty strong
about 1900
it's like 375 look at that
that's [ __ ] Oh so kick them in the
nuts and he pushed a barbell down
wait you cheat them into knots yeah [ __ ]
the Xuan's nuts area why'd you give me
the nuts bro what is it you want to get
to make funny work there or on the gym
yeah why don't you why don't they like
oh he touched up I wouldn't I'm not a
violent person
I should so [ __ ] no as soon as he
[ __ ] kicked the bar down and lifted
his legs that's when you apologize Oh
cuz I even let somebody did that I would
be in Sochi so such shock I wouldn't
know what to do but the moment he like
puts his hand like here and then he
pushes me then it's like oh I guess we
have to fight now I'm scared that he's
gonna hit me you know so it's like oh my
god great patience on that kid dude yeah
handled it so well cuz he ended up
leaving to humanity about by a
non-member I mean but not bad for this
kid cuz you could clearly tell like so I
like oh if you guys don't know and a lot
of the commercial gyms they don't like
powerlifting cuz it's like the weights
are kind of heavy yeah I know
but he but he he was trying to do as
much as he could with bringing those
mats off to the side and deadlift on the
soft mats and not create that much noise
he's in the like miscellaneous
cross-training section that's why you
see like the monkey bars and like the
battle rope all in the side so he was
trying to like give the gym its space so
after doing all of that that bodybuilder
guy who was wearing a powerlifting brand
shirt what was he wearing animal Oh like
animal holds like the most hardcore
powerlifting events Arnold Olympia they
have this thing called the animal cage
where people go crazy they're bleeding
and [ __ ] blood squirting I don't know
so he's he's wearing that brands shirt
and he's completely oblivious to what
that sports about he comes over and just
kicks the bottle that I need the kids
strapped into you strapped into the
devil you know anyways you're strapped
and of course Steve knows we're only
work it's hard to pull out and it's easy
to snap your back oh boy children yeah
like it's too loud or what because I
didn't see your I watched it on mute
even with the hem far away so those pads
he was instructed by the workers there
that if he wanted to deadlift that he
has to use those pads so much about the
story is there more to it I was reading
oh yeah because I was like watching it
it actually made me I haven't watched a
video in a long time brother you wanted
to fight for him if you saw that going I
did if you guys saw that go down in the
gym would you just throw hands no I
would probably stop it oddly oh this
guy's a kid you're a full-grown man
don't you don't have to put like here he
was roid rage and though like he was
raising his voice he was touching him
and I think he was ready to fight do
butter purrs you know what happened his
girlfriend broke up with them that day
we did you know that no I made it up oh
I see at 24 hour fitness when when cliff
and I used to work out in the morning
there there was a huge buff dude and his
girlfriend there all the time and I
would specifically go at 9:00 a.m. just
to watch them because it was the most
hilarious interaction ever seen in my
life because he was like raged out all
the time so she would do something right
and he comes up babe [ __ ] told you
and this she's over there crying every
day she would and then he would just so
she said you're just like she's crying
as he's yelling at her every [ __ ] day
yeah and it's like dude this guy has an
anger issue that's intended yeah I just
never seen somebody just yell and then
kiss his girlfriend didn't matter
bipolar ass
I just want to see if I go down so I can
be break it up guy what did I get
immediately dispatched that's right love
I love a good breaking up guy not like a
really good breaking up guy but then but
they break it up guy who like it
immediately gets like throw now it's the
ground break it up guys you're tall like
lewin little guys try to break things up
they get [ __ ] up in a crossfire that's
what I love I love those guys I love do
you want to get there you want to be the
guy that gets [ __ ] up no I want to be
the guy who's like hey let's break it up
guys
and then he immediately just gets thrown
to the side immediately I want to be the
girl that was like in the McDonald's
fight we're like I want to break it up
but then I want to get sucked in somehow
my gosh [ __ ] that's me I always break it
up but I always like secretly wished
someone suck me in somehow cuz you want
to fight you want to be bad at you
badass I get it I get it I get it
if you're gonna work that hard of your
body you gotta be able to use it at some
point that's the reason I wish I was 17
again but with my knowledge and strength
now hmm I don't I don't I was a [ __ ]
toothpick man but what if you could keep
like a new adult height and everything
now but then you're you're just age is
like 16 I just be a fat 16 year old kid
I think it's all that other you are
better I wish I had that my strength now
but I was three years old with this
little kid that's my cooking pot yeah
yeah superpowers I've always wanted to
do that like we'll be messin with my
friends like little brothers and I just
want to pick them up like it's in the
movies and I'm like stand on its down of
the chair yeah the nice standing on the
chair now I feel all strong but then if
I move the chair then my mom comes back
down I remember that we pretend to
excite my brothers and [ __ ] yeah it's
like staying on the couch or it's like
slowly ways to the couch I'm like yeah
this guy did you guys meet my cousin Joe
before John no he lives here little
brother yeah yes yeah [ __ ] his little
big brother I [ __ ] it what I love the
Powerball feels like my favorite
wrestling move right here's the problem
laptop I've lifted him up under the legs
flip them over right but the momentum
brought me backwards I step back and I
pop it straight into the hardwood floor
[Music]
hi powerbomb Stanley Wong through his
[ __ ] closet door like like I fall off
who's Stanley Wong's dolls like my
little friend no that's what
five-year-olds do when they tell stories
like as if you should know their the
first name first of us you have to store
each other you have to say first laugh
my best friend's name was Michelle see
you exactly but she was an Asian no I
powered by my kid through a [ __ ]
closet
although I thought it was called a
jackknife but what you just described is
in fact what the move that I said it's a
jackknife powerbomb rock shows the fool
so that is the maneuver that I that I
initiated as well and I talked about it
scientifically but I was a [ __ ]
little kid and being a [ __ ] do you
remember the Kurt Angle Slam which one
Rosella the Kurt Angle Slam is where you
just grabbed them it's like I guess it's
almost like going for a high single yeah
but then you you use this arm and you
wrap them wrap their arm this way and
you flip over this when you slam into
small [ __ ] oh I couldn't do that so did
somebody do it to me no I did it to Joe
again slammed them into my bed and then
I bet my bed frame in half right but
then my mom was so pissed she just had
me sleep on that bed for a whole year so
I would literally have to sleep at the
furthest edge of the bed or I would roll
off [ __ ] smash it leaned over so
every night I would sleep close to the
wall oh yeah I had that too
no I poke my mirror so my brother would
always [ __ ] with me one time I just
[ __ ] kicked them in his chest and he
blew off the bed and then he you know
those near the closet sliding door
sliding door and this mirror and then he
went like she's back went straight into
that that's it yeah why had to keep I
had to keep that it was all [ __ ] up
and I'm like mom it's glass that's tight
you kicked the guy across the room not
six so did the internet find who this
guy was and then just go after him like
they always do I love it they did they
did report that this guy got kicked out
of the gym and so did another employee
that was involved in this thing did he
lose his steroid sponsorship I don't
know that the other employee do they
just mentioned that he was just old
that's all I know punished to the other
employee being fired yeah they both got
kicked out so he was like down what do
you mean that like he was condoning
whatever happened gathered gym owner
yeah so then gym owner nothing employee
no no so you're saying that he the gym
owner was pissed
oh my employees he said you keep condone
it and then you said yeah the gym owner
oh my bad okay so anyway what they're
reporting here is that the kid got a
lifetime membership to his dream gym and
because that ball brigade clothes kind
of SSP barbell club barbells in it the
word barbell but yeah it's French
barbell brigade yeah do I hate for that
to happen to me though like not that
part but like we're a gym comes up
because you have free membership for
life and the like I have to workout for
the rest of my life now I don't have an
excuse like where were you what you have
a free membership I'm a cottage I knew
you know the gym that was involved in
all of this because they're saying that
they 80% of their members are first time
gym users so they don't really cater
it's like the power losing wow yeah so
then they were reporting that they were
offering the kid a lifetime membership
there but then the kid was like no they
didn't they just offered me a year but
it's fine I don't even want to work out
there cuz that's not even a place wrong
crowd yeah exactly
80% is new members it's like I imagine
that
like it's probably like planet like
Planet Fitness it's like they're trying
to hit that entry-level workout our
person damn but they attract [ __ ]
roid rage weirdos huh
all right now he got kicked out that's a
whole thing to do though because you
don't know if that kid [ __ ] has a
knife or something that's he's power
lifting that'd be tight dude okay you
know what bro right I just pound the
thing about this is exactly what else
they said I was paranoid all these beers
don't get it son of a [ __ ]
well maybe I'm just speaking for myself
I love guys justified to carry publicly
carry weapon
and he finally had the day calm yep hey
hey you guys laugh about that but watch
when the day comes I'm stabbing somebody
[Laughter]